SCORE!
[ HORN ]
>> I BELIEVE IT WAS RIGHT HEITHE
BACKHAND.
[ HORN ]FLEE AND NICHUSHKIN IS
>> ANDREW BURS UP THE TOP OF THE
FAR CIRCLCL MAN DOES HE
HAVE QUICK HANDS.
PAST!
[ HORN ]
REAR-VIEW MIRROR, FOLKS.
THAT SWEET LITTLE BACKHAND PASS
SHORTHANDED GOALS AT SIX.
ANYBODY ON THE ICE CAN DO
PUSHED BACK DOWN AND WHAT A
IT COMES TO FOR THE
RED WINGS.
SHOOTING SHOT,
BACKHAND FLIP -- SCORE.
OH, NO!
THE RED WINGS HAVE MADE IT WORSF
THE GOAL, ITORES
VOLCANO NATHAN MacKINNON! ONE-TO
NATHAN MacKINNNN BACKHAND FLIP
AND THE AVS HAVENT.
WE'RE TALKING 36 GOALS IN SIX G!
I'M SORRY.
I WAS LISTENING
THE OAL TRIANGLE.
NOT REALLY A SCORE.
HARDEST PART FOR ME, MOSE, I BY.
>> AVS ON THE FIVE SCORE!
[ HORN ] CROSS TO THE LOW SPOT O